好,接下来给大家讲一下Triton算子开发的基础模式
让大家对于这个Triton算子的写法有一个基本上的了解
首先呢,我们来讲一下Triton的关键接口
Triton的接口呢,从功能上来说
大体上可以分为两类
一类是做我们算子的开发
也就是Triton,还有Triton.language
还有一类呢,就是做我们算子的正确性验证
就是这个triton.testing
我们今天呢,就是主要来讲一下这个Triton开发的这两类接口
首先是这个Triton里面,它有四个接口
第一个是triton.jit
这个接口的作用呢,其实也是最重要的
因为它的作用就是指定我们的某个函数
是我们的Triton算子
它就是说会指定我们的这个函数呢
用我们的Triton编译器去做jit编译
像下个例子,大家可以看到
我们这里面写了一个函数
给它,当然里面还做了一些实现
这里省略掉了
然后呢,我们就需要在这个函数的这个定义前面呢
去给大家加一个triton.jit
这样它就会告诉编译器会知道
这个函数我们需要用Triton的编译器来做编译
然后呢,就是我们这个triton.jit
它的作用呢是自动调优
也就是说为我们的Triton编译器呢
它里边一些关键参数的选择
去做一个自动调优
把里边效果最好的这个参数选出来
它的用法呢,其实是说我们给它手动的提供很多个Config
Config里边呢,就可以有我们一些关键参数的取值
那我们给了很多Config之后
通过这个triton.autotune把这些Config包起来
它运行的时候呢,就会自动的去给我们做测试
相当于说把这些Config都跑一遍
然后再给我们选出哪个Config是性能最好的
然后这里面呢,我们还会给它一个这个关键参数
就是这个key
key里边的列表呢,也是代表我们这个Triton函数的一些参数
但它的意思是说,每次当这个key里边参数的值发生变化
它就会重新去做这些Config的测试
比如说,这个key里边通常我们会放上这个数据的总量
比如说总大小
因为很多情况下呢,我们根据这个不同的计算量的大小呢
我们需要给里面的这个数据分块做不同的切分
那这个时候呢,对于每一个不同的size
它都会做一遍这个测试
把所有的Config都Apply一遍
然后去在里面为每一个key的取值
来选出我最好的Config
然后呢,就是这个triton.Config
其实这个就是这里边的Config
我们通过它呢,来创建一个
我们在自动调优的时候去做尝试的选择
里面呢,可以写上一些编译器的内在参数
比如说在我们的Triton里边
我们就只是像MultiBuffer
这种来控制我们做这个多Buffer
加强这个并行化的这么一个优化
还有就是我们也可以通过这个kwargs
来做这个自定义的关键字参数
然后这里呢,我们就可以把我们分块的大小
BLOCK_SIZE给放到这个kwargs里边
然后去为这个BLOCK_SIZE去做自动调优
所以这两个东西是组合着来用的
最后一个呢,就是triton.heuristics
它的作用其实是说也是为我们来推导一个
某个关键参数的一个取值
但它的作用呢,并不会像triton.autotune一样
去给每个我们的怀疑的对象去做一次尝试
它会是直接写我们的某个参数和另一个参数之间的计算方法
像在这个例子里面,我们写的就是说
BLOCK_SIZE的取值,就是根据我们这个
size的下一个2的幂的大小来取
相当于说直接就指定了这两个参数之间的关键
这个它的作用其实就是可以代替
在一些场景下代替triton.autotune
比如说如果我的config过于多了
或者我们觉得triton.autotune的成本太大
那这个情况下我们就可以用triton.heuristics去
直接指定我们的计算方法
就不用为很多的config去做triton.autotune的测试了
接下来再给大家介绍一下triton.language的接口
像前一页提到过的Triton的接口
它们主要是用来写在Triton函数的外面
而triton.language的接口通常是被我们放在函数的里面
来给提供函数的具体实现的
我们可以看到它里面提供了很多种不同类型的接口
这些不同类型的接口可以充分的支撑我们去做算子的开发
验证还有调用
那这里面就挑最重要的
而且也是最常用的一些给大家做一个介绍
首先就是ProgrammingModel里面的Tensor
所以它准确说不是个接口
它是一种类型
也就是基本的多维张量结构
也就是我们大多数的Triton接口的操作数和返回值
然后呢
还有里面的我们把它当一对的接口来介绍吧
首先就是program_id
它其实就是给我们返回一个编号或者说下标
代表的是我们在指定的某个轴上的ID
它的这个轴的范围是3D的范围
而num_programs呢
它返回的就是我们的在某个指定轴上
我们总共启动多少个实例
范围也是3D
那这两个接口为什么重要呢
就是因为我们的Triton呢
是SPMD的编程方式
我们Triton本身的写法会自动发射很多个并行的逻辑核
让它们同时来做这个计算
但是呢它们执行的又是同一份代码
所以在这个代码中呢
我们就需要有这个program_id
让每个这个逻辑核都知道自己要处理的是哪些数据
所以说这块就是这两个函数
有很高的必要性
还有就是在Cristian OP里面
这里面呢我们最常用的其实就是一个arange接口
它的作用就是返回一个half-open区间的连续数字
而且它的这个起点和终点呢
有一个长度上的限制
这个东西我们通常呢
用来是做跟访问有关的一些操作
我们用它来生成我们的Offset
因为比如说我们如果说想在我们的函数里
Load或者Store一串连续的数据
这个时候呢我们就可以用这个arange的这个函数
给我们通过返回一串连续的数字呢
来作为我们的这些一段连续数据的Offset
然后只要给这些Offset呢
再加上我们这个这段数据的起点的指针
那就可以作为我们的Load函数的输入
来让我们的逻辑核去从片外把数据取到片上
所以这个也基本上是每个函数
每个Triton函数都必不可少的一个接口
然后就是这个full它的作用也很明显
就是返回一个被指定类型的标量值填满的一个Tensor
通常来说呢我们可以用它去创建一些我们的计算中的一些默认值
然后放在我们的算子里面
然后就是跟我们的这个访存相关的接口
其实就是一对Load还有Store
因为我们的Triton呢
对于数据的这个内存的结构
还是有一些控制能力的
也就是说我们需要这个开发者来控制这个
把数据从片外给搬到片上
然后计算完呢再把数据从片上给搬回片外
所以这一刻我们就需要这个Load和Store
那它的做法就是我们先是给它提供Pointer
然后呢这个Pointer里边其实会体现我们需要
Load多少数据
比如说我们如果想Load连续8个数据的话
我们可以在这块先arange一个0到8
然后呢把这个结果的Tensor呢
再加上我们这个再给一个片外内存的一段起点
然后它要知道
然后把那个结果的那个Tensor放到这里面
它就知道我们要从以那个指针为起点
连续去取8个数据
然后呢它还提供了这个Mask这个参数
Mask作用其实就是说我们可以筛选出一些我们需要去Load的数据
比如说这个我们的8个数里边我们只需要其中的5个
那么先说把剩下三个的Mask给搞成0就行了
这样就不会去帮我们计算的三个Mask
然后下面的Store也是一样
其实呢就是主要是Pointer
这回Pointer代表就是我们Pointer内存的这个指针的位置
然后呢就把我们的这一块Value的数据
或者说我们的这个Tensor给存到我们的Pointer
然后呢也是可以通过我们这个Mask参数
去指定哪些数据给存在这个指定的Pointer内存的位置
这些基本就是我们写一个算子
最重要的一些接口
在后边用例一点大家也可以看到这些接口的实践
接下来呢我就讲一下Triton Kernel的一个整体的开发模式
Triton呢它的做法其实就是会自动的发射很多个逻辑核
当然具体发射多少个
这个数量也是我们来指定
然后呢它会根据逻辑的核数呢
把计算数据切块为多个block
当然每个block的大小其实也是我们来给的
然后这样呢我们不同的逻辑核就会做一个并行的计算
宏观上的并行来计算这个不同块的数据来拼成我们最终的一个结果
Triton呢它是SPMD的开发模式
也就是说我们所有的逻辑核
它们会共用同一段Triton Kernel的代码实现
也就是说它们进行了里边的操作啊
其实逻辑都是一样的
那这样我们就需要根据我们这个每个Triton的逻辑核的自己的ID
来让它不要来重复计算其他逻辑核的数据或者计算任务
所以每个逻辑核它都需要有这个在里面获取自己的ID
然后呢每个核呢它其实只计算一个block的数据
它就需要这个根据我们的核ID来计算我们对应数据的位置
这样最后才能把我们的所有的计算完的结果来拼成我们完整的计算结果
然后呢它的实现呢我们可以分为两段来介绍
一个是外面对它的调用
还有就是这个Triton Kernel它本身的实现
我们从外向里的这个方向来讲哈
首先这个调用上哈
我们需要在这个Triton Kernel的外面去创建它这个Tensor
而且对数据做初始化
那这样的话呢它对这个Tensor
其实是创建在了我们的片外内存上
然后呢我们再把这个这些片外内存的指针给传到我们的Triton Kernel的参数里面
然后我们调用的时候呢我们会有额外的参数就是grid
这个参数它控制的就是逻辑核的数量
这个grid呢它也是一个多维的最多到三维的一个参数
也就是说我们可以控制一个在三维的一个方向去发射我们的一个逻辑核
然后在Triton Kernel内部呢我们的这个流程呢首先第一步都是获取我们逻辑核的ID
也就是用之前提到过那个program_id
这个东西就可以让我们的这个逻辑核来识别我到底是第几号这个实例
然后我需要来根据这个ID呢再结合我们的Block Size
来计算我们这些偏移啊这些的参数这样我们就知道我这个核要算的是哪些数据
然后在定位到这些数据之后呢我们就可以去用我们的load
来把我们对应的数据来加载到我们的片上内存
因为我们的计算呢都是必须把这个数据给搬到片上去执行我们的计算任务
然后下一步呢就是我们既然数据都到片上了我们就可以就用那些做计算的OP
或者说这些写好的算子来完成我们的计算逻辑
然后做完这些计算呢我们还要再把这个数据给存回片外
其实就是用我们前面提到的这个Store这个接口
然后呢把我们像我们这个计算完的结果的这个Tensor
就是放在那个Value上
然后呢也是根据我们的逻辑核的ID和Block Size
去算出来在片外的存储里
我这个应该存在哪一块地址
然后呢就可以用Store把我们的这个数据存到片外了
也就是这个就是我们整体的Triton算子的一个开发的一个范式
大家需要来写出来这个我们核内每个核的这个任务
还有我们外边到底有多少核
这些都需要我们来手动的控制
接下来呢我再给大家带来一个Triton算子用例
帮助大家更好的理解一个Triton算子应该去怎么写
这里呢我给大家带来了一个向量加法的用例
也就是最简单的用例
这个用例呢大家就可以在我们的Triton算子的开发仓里面找到
来做一个基础的入门
在这个用例里呢我们对所有的计算数据
进行了一个分块分成了多个Block
然后每个核内呢我们只对一个Block的数据
进行一个加法
而在我们做这个kernel launch的时候呢
它就已经自动的做了多个逻辑核
也就是多个Block之间的并行
在我们的算子内呢
我们想为这个算子适配升能
其实不需要特殊的语法
这些接口的使用都是和社区是保持一致的
也就是说我们这同一套代码
既可以跑在我们升能上
也可以直接去跑在GPU上
完全不需要任何修改
然后我们再从上到下
给大家过一遍它里面的结构和细节
一开始呢就是triton.jit
这个东西就是这个装饰器嘛
它可以指定下边的add_kernel
是我们的Triton Kernel
也就是说呢在运行的时候呢
它知道把这个算子
这个函数
去交给我们的Triton编译器
去做编译还有调用
然后呢再看见它里面的这些参数
虽然是XY和Output Pointer
这三个指针呢其实就代表了说
我们的两个输入还有我们最后的输出
而这些指针呢都是在我们的片外内存上的
因为我们是在函数外面做的这些数据的初始化
然后再把它传给我们的Triton Kernel
至于说我们怎么把这个数据从片外给搬到片上
或者说怎么再从片上给存回片外
这些都是在我们算的实现内部去做的
然后呢就是n_elements
这个参数的作用呢其实是告诉我们
我们总共有多少个数要算
代表的是一个所有的逻辑核的总计算量
我们需要它是因为我们本身这个计算总量呢
未必能被我们的Block Size整除
用它可以和我们的尾块去做一个对比
来算出我们的Mask
来避免尾块去把数据给算多了
然后我们最后一个参数就是Block Size
可以看到它是一个常量
它就是用来给我们这个Kernel
来指定每个逻辑核内
我们到底算了多少数据
每个逻辑核也就只算Block Size这么多的数
然后在函数内呢
第一步其实就是调用我们的program_id接口
它会给我们返回这个逻辑核的program_id
也就是我们这个逻辑核的编号
这样呢我们就可以用这个编号
可以看到我们首先跟这个Block Size相乘
它就可以算出来我们里边
算的这部分这个数据的
偏移的起始地址的偏移是多少
也就是这个Block Size
然后呢在下面我们再调用我们之前提到过这个arange接口
它会创建一串连续的数据
然后呢我们这里面指定它从0开始
创建这个Block Size这么多
也就是说它会返回一个tensor
就是从0到Block Size-1
然后呢这个arange的结果呢
我们再加上之前算出来的block_start
那它这个就算出来了我们这个逻辑核内
就算的数据的偏移是哪些
然后它那也是一个Tensor
这个Tensor里存放的是一堆连续的数
然后呢这里看到我们还需要设置Mask
Mask的作用其实也主要就是防止我们的尾块
去给我们做这种错误计算或者多余计算
所以这块我们offset就已经指定好了
我们的偏移嘛
但对尾块来说呢
offset里的有一部分数是不需要的
那这部分数呢它的取值会比这个N
NIM更大
所以说这里呢我们用一个很简单的一个小于判断
就可以算出来我们的Mask
那对于我们的完整Block来说
这Mask就是一个完整的
然后但是对于这个我们的尾块来说呢
就会把最后的一些数给屏蔽掉
然后再往下呢我们就可以用load
来把我们的两个输入
X和Y都从这个片外给取到片上
这里呢我们就把之前的算的offset呢
加上我们这个起点的地址
这里呢就相当于说给了很多地址
然后每个地址都代表了我们要load的数据
而且是连续的
他就知道要把这些数据给我们放到片上
然后呢当然再结合Mask
来避免说我们给load太多了
load完之后呢这个加法就是很正常的加法
然后我们把两个取出来的tensor给加起来
然后呢我们的结果的tensor呢
我们在因为offset是一样的嘛
只是说我们的这个起点的这个指针不一样
然后我们就把这个算出来的结果
再跟我们前面的output的这个指针和对应的偏移
来把它存到我们的片上该在的位置
这个就是我们向量加法算子内部的实现
接下来是Triton kernel的调用和运行
大家把这几个关键点也过一下
首先就是我们需要import几个关键的库
首先是这个torch是肯定需要的
还有就是我们面向昇腾的torch插件
也就是torch_npu
再接下来呢就是Triton里面用来做算子开发的两个库
Triton还有triton.language
然后再往下呢就是我们需要在调用之前
在Python内存创建并初始化数据
这里呢我们通过torch.rand
就为这个数据做了一个随机的初始化
同时呢通过我们这个device等于NPU的这个参数
我们也就指定了这个数据的内存的位置
是在我们昇腾的Python内存
注意是Python内存
而不是AI core的片上内存
然后呢就到了我们函数调用的地方
在这里呢第一步我们也是给output也创建了这个Python内存的空间
然后呢我们在调用的时候呢就把xy output给传进去
进去之后呢它就会在算子里拿到这三个Python内存的指针
同时呢我们在这里也把我们的数据总量
还有我们设的block size大小
也就是这个常数也一起传进去
这里还有一个参数就是grid
就是这个用括号括起来的这个参数
它的作用是指定我们总共发射多少个逻辑核
在这里呢我们可以通过直接写数字来给它写死
也可以通过lambda表达式来表达说它对于其他的一个参数的一个关系
比如说在我们这个grid的内部呢
我们每个核要处理的数据在乘以我们的总共的核数
它应该是要覆盖我们所有的计算任务的
所以在这里呢我们就可以通过lambda来写说我们这个grid的取值
就是n_elements这个任务的总量除以我们每个核的block size
那这样呢我们每次手动修改这个block size取值的时候
grid也会相应的做对应的自动的调整
那这个就是整体的Triton Kernel从算子的编写到后面的调用和运行的内容
好的以上就是今天课程的全部内容了
在今天课程中呢给大家带来了Triton的设计理念
如何在昇腾上进行了支持
以及Triton的环境装配和用例运行
还有最后我们Triton算子的整体的一个实现逻辑
在今天课程中呢并没有涉及太多和昇腾相关的算子实现的细节
这些会在后续的进阶课程中出现
感谢大家的观看再见
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目